foreign
this is Kayleen from Burbank
um throughout the years I've moved
several times and every time I've moved
and gotten rid of a bunch of stuff a
couple years later I always go oh my God
I wish I wouldn't have given that away
why did I give that away and then I have
regret about it
so how do you guys suggest dealing with
that
so when we talk about regret what are we
really talking about
we're talking about a sense of loss but
loss is just a story it's not a reality
it loss is a story it's not a reality
right because
regret is a byproduct of the stories we
tell ourselves and so here's what
happens you didn't actually lose
something when you got rid of that you
lost the story that you told yourself
about that item a moment ago we were
just talking about the hate that shirt
rule if you let go of a piece of
clothing and you hated it the story you
tell yourself is I'm so happy I got rid
of it that's just a story you tell
yourself as well you didn't actually
gain anything by getting rid of it you
might have gained some space but that's
also a story that you tell yourself and
that's why these stories are so
empowering or disempowering that's right
when you transform your failures into
strategies for future decision making
you have wisdom but when you treat those
failures as evidence that you're a total
screw-up then you have regret it's all
about the difference in the story that
you're telling it's totally okay to have
those moments where you say ah man I
thought I was right but I don't like the
outcome from that decision that's cool
transform that into wisdom instead of
using it as a reason to hate on yourself
yeah I've heard this question asked a
few times I would love a list of like
the things that they regret because I
would I'm willing to bet that it's
probably not more than a couple items
and the the thing is is when we do tell
ourselves a story that Kaylene is
telling herself and I've told myself
this story too it makes me hold on to
everything just in case which is like
that gives you permission to hold on to
everything and if you start down that
road then you're gonna have way more
items you don't need than you need one
two five ten years from now and the
story We Tell ourselves before we even
let go of it is I'm going to regret this
yeah you say that over and over guess
what's gonna happen you were going to
regret it but if the story is I'm going
to feel so free when I let go of this
I'm gonna feel so free when I let go of
this I'm gonna feel free if I could just
let go and all of a sudden I let go of
it what do I feel I feel free
I feel free because I let go yeah yeah
you know there is something beautiful
about saying I don't want to live a life
that I'll regret but you can become
attached to that too and that can become
a form of clutter because then you live
your life paranoid anxious about every
decision that you make because since
it's always possible you might make a
mistake I might live in regret and the
way you release yourself from that fear
of regret is by trusting in your ability
to improvise trusting in your ability to
adapt I make my decisions not from
perfect knowledge but from an honest
understanding of where I am today and
from a willingness to change in the
future when I get feedback from the
outcome one of my favorite minimal
maxims that I have ever said and I quote
myself here
this is writing that he was quoting Ryan
Nicodemus
uh if I die without any regrets I'm
really going to regret that I love it
but let me unpack that what that means
is like if if I truly died without any
regrets it means I didn't take enough
chances and if I didn't take enough
chances I'm Really Gonna regret that so
it's it's okay to have a little bit of
regrets as long as you uh learn from
those regrets to live a better life and
and to make better decisions then that's
okay like regrets are not a bad thing
they don't feel good at the time but
like you said man like something we can
learn from now Kayleen if she's got a
list of 100 things that she got rid of
and she's like oh there's 100 things I
shouldn't get rid of then I would say
okay maybe the boundaries that you're
setting up for yourself maybe those have
to you got to revisit those to see um if
you're you know letting go of the of the
appropriate things or sometimes life
just changes and that's okay too like
that's that's a constant it's always
going to change there are different
seasons and yeah holding on holding on
to everything though just in case for
those those Seasons that show up or I I
guarantee that would cause more
overwhelm than having to replace you
know something for less than twenty
dollars in less than 20 minutes aka the
2020 rule that's right the just in case
rule here's what I'll tell you about
regret in my own sense in my own
personal life
I've let go of a lot of things and I
don't regret letting go of any of them
however
there are certainly things I've let go
of that I have regret at some point but
if I hold on to the regret that's when
the regret becomes a problem so what
you're saying is she's so good at
letting go she can just let go of that
regret if she wants to ah spot on that's
great man spot on Kayleen I'm going to
send you a copy of our book everything
that remains Ryan and I wrote this
almost a decade ago now actually we
wrote it a decade ago it came out almost
a decade ago it's a story about changing
the stories we tell ourselves about what
it means to be successful about what it
means to hold on what it means to let go
and the stories that we associate with
those so if you enjoy our podcast I
think you'll enjoy the audiobook version
of everything that remains it's my
favorite book that we've ever written or
if you want the book book or the ebook
version I'll be happy to send those to
you as well did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
advertisement free